Tu connais la voix de Beckham ?
Une gâterie sur une bonbonne d'hélium.
Je suis désolé.
Pardonne-moi.
Je regrette.
Tellement !
Trop tôt ? Oui, trop tôt.
Lo siento!
(Je suis désolé)
Amor, lo siento!
(Mon Amour, je suis désolé)
Des tickets pour la Coupe du Monde ?
Vivement qu'on ne regarde pas Italie / Pays-Bas ensemble.
Comment t'en vouloir ?
Câlin-réconciliation. Voilà !
Ça fait un bien fou.
Tu sens si bon !
Parfum Canelle-Testostérone.
- Restons comme ça.
- Non, il faut pas.
Vivons nos émotions à fond, c'est si beau.
Pourquoi t'es désolé, au fait ?
Le truc dans Deadpool, avec la voix...
Je vois pas.
- À ton avis, c'était pour quoi ?
- Par où commencer ?
- Green Lantern, RIPD...
- Horrible.
- Renaissances...
- Affreux.
Blade : Trinity...
- Le Monstre du Campus.
Le Monstre du Campus est un chef d'oeuvre !
David, désolé de t'avoir crié dessus.
J'ai perdu les pédales.
Ouvre-moi s'il te plaît.